it's 11:00 a.m. at the Rio Club Hotel
Resort on Gran Canaria for the last hour
professional host Yuri slay lay out
Gonzalez has been putting a group of
vacationers through their paces after
some stretching she moves on to a
30-minute aqua aerobics session
Yuriy as her friends caller was born in
Cuba she's lived on Gran Canaria for
seven years she works at the 4-star
resort five days a week
he Agathe caviar my work is all about
energizing the guests I'm constantly
talking to people and I like to convey
urge what have you that's the most
important thing positive energy and good
vibes not everyone can do that you have
to be a certain type to do this kind of
work locally in the West this sort of
hotel tends to attract families the team
of hosts is a big draw for them many
people booked a stay here because of the
wide range of activities
the resort is in mass Palomas one of the
most popular destinations on the island
tourism is Gran Canaria is most
important industry Yuri has worked here
for three years now
one of her main duties is maintaining a
good relationship with guests this hotel
is just perfect we've been coming here
for 13 years every year we come here and
we just feel great at 12:30 it's time
for the rehearsal for the evening
performance along with speaking several
languages and being physically fit the
job requires acting and dancing talent
too as a trained dancer that part comes
naturally to Yuri but it still took her
a while to grow into the job when you
start out the job can be stressful you
think oh god I have to do this then I
have to run to the next thing
but once you get used to it and have fun
with it it's no problem you find a
rhythm you prepare activities leave them
eat lunch go home do the evening show
then it starts all over again after the
rehearsal the team meets to discuss the
upcoming activities there are 17 hosts
working here
today the activities director of the
hotel chain is here as well
Gerhardt Cotswolds from Austria he's
responsible for recruiting and training
the team and knows exactly what sort of
people he's looking for they can't be
shy
they have to be friendly and talented
when it comes to our evening shows they
can't be nervous on stage or with the
microphone in their hand they need to be
outgoing at 3 o'clock the team gives a
small performance by the pool and lets
the guests know what activities are
planned for the afternoon before URI
leads her next activity she shows us
what some of her colleagues are up to
while Maria from Spain is doing strength
training Nena from Germany is in the
hotel's art studio helping guests get in
touch with their creativity
a few meters away a Dutch colleague is
doing the same but with younger guests
at 3:30 Yuri's working again this time
giving a salsa class Yuri lives off-site
she's also a mother which doesn't leave
her much time for herself
boy when I go on holiday I go somewhere
where there are no people then I can
have time and space for myself somewhere
quiet where I can relax with no stress
of course I love partying and excitement
but that's not what I'm looking for in
my own holiday : idealist
Yuri eats dinner at home then she's back
at the resort at 8:30 in time to prepare
for the evening performance
yeah that a lot huh I do get tired after
a typical day of classes looking after
the guests and generally having a lot to
do but at the same time I still have
energy and I look forward to the
performances I love my job so it never
feels like a chore
tomorrow at 10 o'clock it all starts
again URI will be back making sure the
guests have a holiday to remember